this is a jump-scare surprising yeah
unexpected probably loud most definitely
but is it scary let's take another look
hmm
I'm still not so sure how about another
look ah see if you're in the majority
you may have just braced yourself or
lowered the volume of your computer so
that you wouldn't be as jarred by the
jump scare but in the end is it just
scary because it's surprising or loud or
startling that's what I'm trying to
answer but to be perfectly honest I
don't really care about that answer
myself and more to the point I plan on
speaking much softer so that some of you
may have to turn up your volume in order
to be able to hear me and then in the
darkness to be able to hear something
rattling in your house something
standing behind you that you didn't
notice the whole and you're too afraid
to turn around now because what if it
actually is there you see the argument
for what something is and why something
is or is not scary it's not important
because in the end you'll find that
there's much worse things waiting for
you than a simple happy Halloween
hey you were expecting a jump-scare